Let us see if we can understand
how caches become incoherent.
Suppose that we have a memory location
A that initially contains a zero value.
In this system we have three cores.
Each core has it's own
write-back L1 cache.
And these write-back caches do
not have any coherent support.
This means that this write-back
L1 cache is simply behave
as if each of these caches was
just alone in a uni-processor.
So they behave correctly for
a uni-processor cache, but
they do not try to maintain coherence.
And this is what the three cores do.
Core 0 loads from A into a register,
increments the value in the register,
and then stores the register
back into memory location A.
Sometime later, core one does
pretty much the same thing.
It loads A into a register, increments,
and writes the register back to A.
And finally,
core two does the same thing.
Note that these are happening one
after the other, so without cashes,
core zero would be loading zero,
writing a one, read one on core 1,
put a two back in A, and
then here we read two and put a three.
But with the three L1 caches and
no coherent support, the question for
you is the value that core A is
writing to A here can be, what?
Can it be 0, can it be 1, can it be 2,
can it be 3, can it be 4 and
can it be something larger than 4?
Put a check next to all of the answers
that might be true for this right here.